WESLEY CHUN: Hey, all.
This is Wesley Chun.
Welcome to another Google
Apps Script episode.
If you're new to that
technology, pause and click
on the link in the
description below
to watch the intro video
first, then rejoin us here.
All right.
Now you may be
wondering, accessing
Google Maps from a spreadsheet?
Sound crazy?
Did you think I made it up
just to get your attention?
Well, quite the
opposite actually.
In this video, I'll teach you
to write code that not only does
what's advertised, but also
why it's useful to do this.
And that little star there
means that I may also
throw in a little extra surprise
at the end, so stay tuned.
In this episode, we're going to
start with a new Google sheet
and put some data in it,
such as a street address.
Then we're going to
have our spreadsheet ask
Google Maps to create a
map for us, specifically
a map of that address
that's in the spreadsheet.
This is fine and all,
and you can easily
imagine more than
one address, right?
The problem is putting each
address into Google Maps.
You'd have to go back
and forth between Maps
and the spreadsheet, right?
Well, what if I could just
click a link in the spreadsheet?
That's what we're going to do.
To complete the circle,
we'll save a link
to that map back into
the Google sheet.
As mentioned earlier, the
technology we'll be using
is Google Apps Script.
The documents and spreadsheets
in your Google Drive
can actually be programmed
using a subset of JavaScript
called Apps Script.
Apps Script code can
access data in Google Apps,
as well as call other
Google services,
Google Maps being one of them.
Again, if you haven't
seen that video yet,
or if you're new to Apps Script,
please check it out first.
The link is still
in the description.
It hasn't moved since
we last mentioned that.
Or here it is for
your convenience,
if you're on a computer.
Another reason to
watch it first is
because we're going to build
on its "Hello World" example
that you see here.
If you're all set, then
let's go to the computer now.
All right.
Before we get started, I want
to strongly encourage all of you
to do this with me,
because doing the hands-on
is much more valuable than
just watching a video.
You can pause and resume
as often as you need to,
because I'm not going anywhere.
We're going to take what we
learned in the first Apps
Script episode and
build on from there,
allowing your spreadsheet
to talk to Google Maps.
Just like we did the last
time, go to Google Drive
and create a new Google sheet.
When you're done, come
back and join me here.
All right.
Let's go.
Start at the first cell and
put any street address into it.
For example, we'll use 76
9th Avenue in New York.
Feel free to expand
your spreadsheet columns
if you need to make them wider
so that you can see everything,
but it's optional.
And that's it.
It's time to write some code.
Go up to the Menu
bar and select Tools.
Then pull down Script Editor.
Just like in the
previous episode,
we're going to start
with Blank Project,
because we're not
really going to write
that many lines of code.
Four, to be exact.
And also just like
the last episode,
we need to get the
current spreadsheet,
so we're going to
use Spreadsheet
App and its Get
Active Sheet method
to get the current sheet.
This time, let's save it
to a variable-named sheet,
because we're going to
use it more than once.
Naming make sense, right?
All right.
Last time, we used
the Get Range method
to get the first cell,
which was A1, remember?
We're going to do
something similar.
We're going to use
Get Range again,
and we're also going
to use the A1 notation.
Let's just confirm that by
taking a quick peek back
at the spreadsheet to
confirm where our address is.
And there it is.
But instead of using Set
Value to write "Hello World"
into that cell, we're going
to use Get Value to pull out
the address and save that
to a variable-named address.
Again, appropriately-named.
All right.
Now here comes the magic part.
Spreadsheet App is the
Apps Script endpoint
for accessing Google Sheets.
Now in order to
talk to Google Maps,
we need an equivalent object.
And that's going to be Maps.
As you can see here, the
Maps object has many methods,
but the one we care
about is New Static Map.
What are we going to do?
We're going to create
a new Google map,
but we also want a map that
has a pin on that address that
was in the first column.
The way you do that is you pass
the address to the Ad Marker
method, like you see
there, and now let's
save the map to a
variable named "that."
Again, appropriately-named.
Then the final step
is to store a link
to that map in the cell next to
the address in the spreadsheet.
So we're going to use the
sheet's Get Range method again,
also A1 notation.
We saw a moment ago that the
cell next to the address is B1,
so this time we're going to use
its Set Value method in order
to write that map's
link to the cell.
And you can get that by using
the Maps' Get Map URL method.
And that is it.
Oh.
If you haven't named
your script yet,
you're going to be
prompted, as before,
to do so when you
save or run it.
We'll call it Google Maps demo,
for lack of a better name.
Now when we run it
again, you'll see
that we need to do
the OAuth thing,
and grant this code access
to our spreadsheet data.
Once you opt-in and are able
to run it successfully--
and you can tell it's done when
the yellow run dialog shows
up and disappears-- and if
everything went according
to plan, when we pop back
into the spreadsheet,
you'll see the map's
link in cell B1.
There it is.
And if you click
on it, you'll see
that it's the map that we asked
Google Maps to make, along
with a pin at that address.
Isn't that awesome?
All right.
That's it.
We only needed four
lines of JavaScript
connecting a spreadsheet
to Google Maps.
Hope you enjoyed this
demo, and more importantly,
are able to see how,
in a few lines of code,
you could do something
that could almost
be considered useful.
So was this all for show?
Was this just a party trick?
How can you take
this and turn it
into something really useful?
Well, there are
many possibilities.
Perhaps you've got the addresses
of all your local customers
in New York City, and want
to plot them on a Google Map
to help you plan to visit
them all in a single day.
Well the code you just
completed is your launch point.
Or maybe this is the
monthly user group.
Or a club meeting.
Right?
Well instead of manually
entering in the spreadsheet
data, perhaps you
pulled the membership
so that the data comes
from a Google form.
As you can guess
by now, Apps Script
gives you the ability to turn
generic, boring spreadsheet
data into an app, processing
and managing member info as well
as possible meet-up locations.
To find out more
about what you can
do with Google Maps
from Apps Script,
check out the first
link that you see here.
Of course, Apps Script gives
you access not only to Maps,
but other Google services, too.
To find out about what other
services are available to you,
check out the second link.
Finally, the resources
at the bottom
will point you to more episodes
in this and other developers'
series where you can subscribe
to always get our latest
episodes.
That's it for now.
But as you can guess, it's
just the beginning for you.
Stay tuned for future
episodes, where
we'll do more stuff
with Maps, Forms,
and explore other Google
services from Apps Script.
This is Wesley Chun from Google,
and we'll see you next time.
What-- wha-- you're still here?
It's over.
Go back to work.
All right.
Fine.
Apparently you won't go away
until you get some more.
All right.
Let's go back to
the computer, then.
When we last left off,
we had just gone back
into the spreadsheet to
click on the link in the cell
next to the address to see
the map that Google Maps had
generated.
Let's go back to the code and
revisit the fourth and final
line.
Sure, it's a good
demo of how you
can write data such as the map's
link back to the spreadsheet,
but we can do something
more exciting, right?
Follow along with me and
change the first part
of the line, specifically
this part here.
Call the MailApp object's
Send Email method.
Oh, and by the way,
choose the second one
that takes three parameters.
We'll start with your friend's
email address as the recipient.
Also enter a subject line.
Choose something like,
I don't know, map?
And finally, reuse
the link to the map
as the body, which is
the final argument.
And that's it.
Any guess as to what this does?
Hint-- it's got something
to do with Gmail.
Yes, that's right.
Instead of writing the link
back to the spreadsheet,
don't you think it's
way more cool to send
this map to my friend?
Well in this demo, I'm just
going to send it to myself,
but you can pretend it's
your friend for now.
All right.
Save, and run as usual.
Notice that you get
another OAuth prompt here.
This time, it's for you to
give this script permission
to send email on your behalf.
Oh.
By the way, be sure the
email that your app sends
does not violate Gmail's
terms of service and program
policies.
But that's a no-brainer, right?
Then go ahead and accept.
And when it's done,
let's check our Gmail.
There's the message.
Boom!
If your friend clicks on
the link in the message
that he or she receives, they'll
see the same auto-generated map
that you saw earlier, and
can now meet you at the party
to celebrate your
awesome coding skills!
Wow.
So what were we left with?
A four-line script
that now interacts
with three different
Google products--
Google Sheets, Google
Maps and Gmail.
Four lines, that's it.
I'd say this
enhancement is even more
useful and intriguing
than our first version.
We invite you to
use your imagination
to see what you can accomplish
with the power of Apps Script.
Hope you got your
fill this time,
because you need to go back to
work, and I need to go, too.
Happy coding, and I'll see
you soon on another episode.